now the Conservatives might have
outperformed expectations at the local
elections but if the results were
replicated at a general election they'd
be unable to form a majority so is there
really much to celebrate well let's ask
the party's chairman Brandon Lewis who
joins us now so you lost seats lost
councils are you really happy with the
results well I've said actually since
Thursday it was a good night for us in
the sense we gained councils we
outperform what people expected but it's
very much stage one and there is a yeah
we get what we gained we're certainly
excused but I think we will have gained
at the end about seven councils we would
have taken control either from Labour or
from no overall control and we managed
to hold on to councils in London that
Labour said they would turn London
completely we even technically gained
barn it back with the majority of 13 but
I've been very clear about this there's
no complacency we've got a big piece of
work to do it this was just stage one of
what will be a four-year piece of work
it's the real risk here that you're kind
of piling on votes in your comfort areas
so older voters white voters voters in
suburbs and the Shires where labour is
doing the same with kind of metropolitan
voters in cities it feels as if it's
kind of a deadlock that's a stasis that
they've got two losers would you agree
with that assessment no actually I think
two points and if you like at two levels
I think first we'll around the country
over the last few months when I've been
traveling around to all parts of the
country I've seen both of our volunteers
activist candidates and the people on
the doorsteps of all backgrounds all
ages in all parts of the country
supporting what we're doing and actually
getting involved that's a good thing and
actually at a secondary level if that
was the case we wouldn't have held on to
the council's labour expected to win
like Wandsworth Westminster and indeed I
don't put it down to luck at all I put
it down to the really hard work of good
local volunteers good counsellors and
candidates who've been out there talking
about the issues that matter to local
people every day low council tax
particularly ones within Westminster and
good frontline services are you worried
that although you've taken votes off you
kept away from the cities now the real
challenge is taking votes off labour and
if you look at these results that's not
really much evidence that you have been
successful in doing that well again in
London we gained seats from Labour in
Hillingdon and in Barnet of course
we've got a majority of 13 now but I'm
very open about the fact we as I say
we've got work to do over the next four
years this is just stage one in terms of
that level of work and we've got to make
sure that we are talking to people as I
said from all backgrounds exactly what
the prime minister said delivering for
everybody right across the United
Kingdom now earlier in the show we paid
a film from ones with where I went to
YouTube talk to voters and to find out
know what they were feeling about the
main parties and there was one young man
who really stood out to me with what he
said and I'll just read you what he did
say he said as a young man if I put
myself online as a conservative I just
get shouted down I can't say openly I'm
a conservative because if I do people
will just say oh that guys are
conservative bring him down I mean do
you think he's effectively saying that
young people are ashamed to say that
they're conservative
actually I recognised the the challenge
that he's got but I see a very different
way actually what I've seen online not
just for people who once say they
support the Conservative Party but
actually we've seen it with moderate
Labour MPs the abuse that we see online
and the sheer attrition from the hard
left which I think there is an argument
is actually purposely to try and put
people off having proper robust debate
it's why we were very clear about having
a respect pledge we need to have a
robust debate but it's got to be respect
and what we do see online is this really
kind of nasty sometimes really quite
personal actually in some cases even
calling for physical abuse and attacks
it's completely unacceptable we've got
to make sure all of us in public life
prepared to take that on get involved in
the debate both online and in the
general public to create that air space
and more people can feel confident about
coming forward and talking about what
they care about but that I want to go
back to that point as well though
because if people do feel confident to
come out and say I'm a conservative is
that because they're worried about the
image of the party and how it's seen
it's not helped is it for example when
conservative councillors post racist or
Rio repost or racist jokes on social
media and of course I'm talking about a
joke that was made by all posted again
by Rosemarie Carol from pendel Council
and I can't even refer to what she said
because frankly it's pre abhorrent I
mean that is not helping your cause is
it well I what was posted the actual
it was called a joke I don't see as a
joke it's completely unacceptable and
let's be very clear about this because a
lot of misinformation being put out
there the moment I think it's right to
get a chance to just clear that up not
just for her but actually more generally
this was a situation that occurred last
year actually in about June last year
her position has been from the very
beginning that she accidentally posted
something she wanted to delete she was
suspended by the party at that point for
three months the labor run counts which
was of course supported by the BNP at
the time put a punishment in place she's
also gone through diversity training
since then and has been a Conservative
councillor for some time so there's a
lot of misinformation not a lot of facts
out there well it's not can come back
let's not have back into the concept I
think gonna be very clear we don't have
double standards first of all she's been
through training she's apologized she
has had punishment now this was all
dealt with locally at the time I am
going to be having a look at this but
there's also a big contrast between
where we are and where labour are first
of all of course the leader of the
opposition's position is he didn't
understand the mural this is a
councillor who has gone through
punishment and training over here but we
also when we have these issues we deal
with them and she's a good example that
that was dealt with at the time it was
dealt with locally to be fair as well
are you happy with how it's been dealt
because I just want to go back to is
that it's hard because she can't
actually refer to what was written but
it really is a pauran it's repugnant are
you happy with someone like that
representing the Conservative Party who
even if it was an accident
posted on there well let's be very clear
her position is it was an accident she
was suspended she's been through
diversity training the punishment she
had was endorsed by the Labour Party and
the BNP who supported him on that
council at the time he's been very clear
about where the facts are but it is
something I'm going to be having a look
at because we've been very clear from
the beginning in our party if we have an
issue come out as we have done over the
last few months when it comes out we
won't do a Labour Party does and pretend
it doesn't exist we will deal with it so
you're gonna look at it again does that
mean she could be kicked out of the
party I'm not going to prejudge any kind
of due diligence work he's right that we
go through this properly but also again
want to stress this was dealt with
locally last year and the position that
was taken was one that was actually in
not just endorsed by it but actually of
course the council's position was the
Labour Party in their BNP so he's some
if not hypocritical for them in the
position they've taken in the last 24
hours
and I want to you and talk to you now
about brexit and whether a Conservative
Party is on that now it feels as though
they're sort of two ways of looking at
the local election results some people
who support bricks that say it's an
endorsement of the Conservatives
position because of picking up votes in
areas that they would leave if you speak
to Craig Oliver which I did in the paper
review he said that actually he sees it
the opposite way you're not doing well
in the remaining areas because you're
supporting a brexit that means leaving
the customs union and the single market
what's your opinion well I think the low
collections around a wide range of issue
me first would be eight years into
government to be the largest party by
some 3,000 odd councillors I think it's
a very good achievement and I think it's
down to a couple of key things when I've
been traveling around the country what
I've heard these people on doorsteps
talking about particularly through the
situation here with Russia with Syria
actually the way that the our Prime
Minister's shown really good clear
leadership and they support that but I
have to say time and again the issues
people were focused on with the local
issues that councils deal with that
affect our lives every day whether it
was the failure of labour to collect the
rubbish in Burma it was a ridiculously
complicated bin collection system that
people in SATA were talking about all
the potholes all the free car park in
the conservative councils are bringing
in or time and again the fact that
conservative councils deliver lower
council tax that's what you want to talk
about I think perhaps people in your
party prefer we did focus more on those
kind of brexit nationai tans they seems
like every kind of a week there's
another router way should be on things
like the customs union can you say
definitively when the UK will be leaving
the customs union under your
government's plan as a prime minister
said we will leave the customs union we
leave the European Union at the
obviously next year that we may have the
implementation period would that will be
delivered as we said we would and
there's no change the position of prime
ministers taken and when you asked on
Friday if we'd be staying in the customs
union until 2023 you said that cabinet
would be making some decisions on that
so had those decisions now been made
actually what I was talking about was
the fact I was being asked about the
decisions and the conversations cabinet
having linked to the meeting last week
which I wasn't at not least I was out on
the campaign trail myself on Wednesday
and I'm not on that committee but
cabinet meets on Tuesday Konami's every
Tuesday and we discuss him what we
in terms of that final deal the we will
negotiate and as my position has been
the same from the very beginning we are
is right that we respect the decision
that was made in that referendum that we
do that in a way that delivers for the
British economy so people can continue
to have opportunities and job growth and
I'm confident the Prime Minister and
David Davis and the team will deliver
that and that we would do that and leave
the European Union and the customs union
as promised let's be real it's gonna be
really hard to stick to the timeframes
no civil servants are asked to go away
and come up with a plan for the customs
relationship with Europe a year ago they
came up the customs partnership that now
looks like that's for the birds we're
not gonna be ready Italian time are we
well this is supposition on where we may
end up over the conversations that going
on I've always found it best not to get
involved in hypotheticals I have great
faith in our wonderful civil service
having worked with him around things
like the piece of work we were doing to
deliver this set of status for European
citizens but they will be able to do
this work and we will be able to leave
the European Union and the customs union
as we've agreed and promised to do do
you think sometimes Teresa may just need
to ignore the people around her cabinet
table ignore the kind of cacophony on
the back benches and just make some
decisions and just get on with it - one
of the great strengths of treasom as
Prime Minister is she's promised to
going through one of the most
complicated processes this country has
seen certainly since the Second World
War in terms of leaving the European
Union and what's involved with that and
in doing that she's bringing the party
together she's bringing the country
together because obviously people in the
country of all parties voted different
ways and I think the fact that she's
working with people to do that in a
really productive way of course
delivered in December the deal that
people said couldn't be done again in
March what people said couldn't be done
that's why I'm very confident that she
will get the right deal for us as we go
forward